tout coiffant de coupe les cheveux en
fait j'étais vraiment
c'est ainsi que cette jeune mannequin
considérer son métier en 1964 un métier
mal considéré également par les
journalistes dès les années 50 un
mannequin on sait ce que c'est ça ne
mange pas sa voix sexe et frivole dans
le meilleur cas locales ont réussi on se
fait épouser par un quelconque
milliardaire et on va vivre dans un
ranch ou dans les palaces internationale
des femmes frivole avides d'une vie
luxueuse un métier que le journaliste
associe à demi-mot à de la prostitution
pourtant ce métier est loin de tout ça
ils demandent des sacrifices des efforts
qu une mannequin rappelé en 1956 qui lie
à l'apprentissage surtout elle doit être
préparé elle doit à mon point de vue
faire beaucoup de culture physique et on
n'arrive pas du jour au lendemain être
mannequin il faut quelquefois plusieurs
mois plusieurs années des mois
d'apprentissage beaucoup de culture
physique mais pour quelle reconnaissance
pour que cette profession soient
reconnus aux yeux de la loi il faut
attendre
1965 cette année-là des mannequins de
créer un syndicat elles prennent la
parole et revendiquent leurs droits
auprès du ministre du travail mannequin
n'est pas qu'être de la pâte à modeler
ici j'ai des familles mannequin qui sont
avec moi qui représente paris lille
grenoble est calme et nous avons des
problèmes de sécurité sociale
d'allocations familiales je n'ai pas eu
à découvrir que ce syndicat était
constituée par des personnes agissantes
j'ai eu à découvrir que qu'elles ont
leurs problèmes leurs problèmes
professionnels et qu'elle avait raison
de venir prouver demi du travail petit à
petit ces femmes ravi son vont avoir un
prénom son nom sortir de l'anonymat les
années 90 c'est l'apogée des super
modèle super star le dicton du jour à la
sainte herbert je reçois achi faire un
vrai plaisir celui de recevoir sur ce
plateau ce soir naomi cambell bonsoir
ces tops modèles vont entrer dans la
culture populaire les top models sont
devenus un véritable phénomène elles ont
même remplacé les stars du grand écran
certaines vont donc devenir célèbre et
riche en 94 selon le magazine américain
forbes cindy crawford a gagné 32
millions de francs suivi de près par
claudia schiffer 26 millions et demi et
stirling comme tout près 25 millions
linda évangéliste par 15 millions et
pauvres nam et quang binh millions
seulement mais bien loin des salaires de
ses top model des années 90 la plupart
des mannequins d'aujourd'hui vivent dans
l'anonymat et dont la précarité de ce
travail aux carrières toujours éphémère
[Musique]